INTERVIEWER 1: This is the
story of a random tip turned
wild goose chase through
the Central American jungle,
a ride on something
called a chicken bus,
and a man who is world
famous to travelers
but completely unknown to most
of the people in his own town.
It's the story of this
man, Alberto Guiterrez.
The person who led the charge to
find Alberto and took the photo
was this woman.
JESSECA KEPPER: Hi.
My name is Jesseca Kepper and
I'm an amateur photographer
from Atlanta, Georgia.
These photographs were
taken on a December morning
back in 2012.
INTERVIEWER 1: Alberto has
been visited, photographed,
and written about
on many travel blogs
and websites over the years.
A quick Google
search will bring up
a lot of sites
offering information
on the Hermit of Nicaragua.
Jesseca first heard about him on
one of these backpacker blogs.
JESSECA KEPPER:
We had originally
planned to spend the extra
week in Nicaragua scuba diving.
But when I found
out about Alberto,
we couldn't pass
up the opportunity
to track him down and
meet him for ourselves.
The Corn Islands
would always be there
for our diving
adventures, but we
didn't know how long the
opportunity would be there
for us to meet a man who
had inspired so many.
INTERVIEWER 1: The inspiration
Jesseca's talking about
comes from hundreds
of stone carvings
Alberto has made over the
years that decorate his home
and the land around him.
JESSECA KEPPER: The journey to
find Alberto Guiterrez included
a few hours on chicken buses
from Managua to Esteli.
The next morning,
we hitched a ride
with a local man about 30
minutes outside of town
to the dirt road where the
adventure really begins.
INTERVIEWER 1: Eventually,
they asked some locals,
who told them to look for small
path that led through a pasture
and into the dense forest.
JESSECA KEPPER: We walked for
probably 10 minutes or so.
Some barking dogs alerted
Allberto to our arrival.
You could feel his energy
and excitement the moment
he greeted us.
He walked us on trails all
over his property for over two
hours, passionately
explaining the inspiration
behind the carvings.
He's in his early
70s, and he's lived
on this land his entire life.
He said he's been carving
for over 35 years.
And he said he carves
three hours every morning,
except when he's sick.
It hard to say exactly
what Alberto is or isn't.
He's definitely a sculptor.
He's a farmer.
He's eccentric.
He's a character, for sure.
Alberto lives in
a one room house
where he had no running water,
no electricity, a dirt floor.
He's never driven a car.
And he has no concept
of the internet really.
And certainly no
true understanding
of how many people have access
to his story through it.
Yet his happiness and his
passion are incredible.
INTERVIEWER 1: At
"This Happened Here",
we're always coming
up with creative ways
to tell stories through photos.
Domain.com is the place to go
when that next great idea hits
you.
It's a one-stop shop for all
of your domain and web hosting
needs.
Because you watched
"This Happened Here",
you can get 20% off new
domains, web hosting, and email
by using the code HAPPENED
when you check out.
This is actually Jesseca's
second story with us.
The first one is
about this photo.
JESSECA KEPPER:
Roadside distractions,
as I like to call them.
I've been visiting them,
again, since I can remember.
But this one is
really a highlight
because of it's obscurity.
INTERVIEWER 1: If
you liked this story
or have photos of
your own, please
let us know in the comments.
We're always looking for
new stories to cover.
Thanks for watching.